bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 14 février la pollution au cyanure
poursuit son oeuvre dans le danube l'eau
contaminée pourrait s'infiltrer dans les
sols en roumanie en hongrie en
yougoslavie
information france 2 il existe une
centaine de sites répertoriés où l'on
trouve du cyanure en france au kosovo la
force internationale de père est
quarante personnes suspectées d'avoir
participé aux dernières violences
commises à à mitrovica entre les deux
communautés serbe et albanaise de chaque
côté du pont qui sépare la ville bernard
kouchner administrateur civil des
nations unies sera en direct depuis
cristina cent mille étudiants français
sur deux millions vivent en situation de
précarité un rapport propose de créer un
revenu étudiants ceux qui vivent en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté contre les
formes héréditaires du cancer du sein
aux états unis on opère en france les
pratiques sont différentes
le spéléologue michel siffre a quitté la
grotte de clamouse après plus de deux
mois hors du temps des hommes michel
siffre sera en direct dès la fin de
cette élite c'est une histoire de marée
mortel qui court depuis les eaux de la
tisza en roumanie jusqu'au danube après
avoir traversé la hongrie et le nord de
la yougoslavie
la pollution au cyanure et à quelques
kilomètres au nord de belgrade depuis
hier les images venues de ces pays
montrent des masses de poissons morts
plus de 83 tonnes auraient été enlevés
des eaux de la tisza et l'on peut
craindre une contamination des sols
commentaires eric lemasson avec
alexandra et dietsch c'est une simple
brèche dans un bassin de décantation
rien de plus mais nous sommes en
roumanie les exploitant australien des
mines d'or locales ne s'embarrasse
visiblement pas trop avec la notion
d'environnement
une simple bresse donc et voilà le
résultat
car c'est directement dans une rivière
que se sont répandus cent mille mètres
cubes d'un poison mortel un résidu de
cyanure utilisé pour séparer l'or de son
minerai la nappe toxiques dérive à
travers les cours d'eau d'europe
centrale depuis deux semaines d'abord la
rivière samos en roumanie puis la tis a
en hongrie et maintenant le danube en
serbie partout les mêmes scènes de
pêcheurs navré qui se serait bien passé
de cette fraîche faussement miraculeuse
les riverains serbe du danube sont
apparemment désemparé pour évaluer
l'ampleur réelle du danger sauf en amont
dans la rivière tisza il y a beaucoup
plus de poids sont morts ici parce qu'il
y a une grande concentration de ces
nuages mais aussi le danube est large et
c'est donc plus diluée les prélèvements
dans les eaux du danube des montre
certes que le cyanure ne fait que passer
un courant propre remplace vite les eaux
polluées mais qu'en sera-t-il à long
terme
qu'en sera-t-il des conséquences sur
l'approvisionnement en eau potable et
sur l'irrigation des cultures ce qui
peut se passer c'est que donc le cyanure
réagissent avec d'autres métaux qui sont
présents dans cette mine est à ce moment
là il ya des dépôts qui se tourne dans
les sédiments au fond de la rivière
et ce sédiment reste tranquille jusqu'à
skin prochaine crue et à une nouvelle
crue du sort ces sédiments se remettre
en suspension et un nouveau risque de
pollution et ça peut se passer pendant
plusieurs années
si les autorités hongroises évoque une
catastrophe écologique comparable à
tchernobyl
les serbes ne se décide que ce soir à
interdire l'utilisation des eaux du
danube ce midi encore dans ce restaurant
de belgrade où servait un plat de
poisson pêché dans les eaux cyanure et
du danube
devant cette pollution au cyanure il
sera donc bien difficile de réparer
avant plusieurs décennies l'équilibré
écologique du bassin du danube curiosité
tout naturel aussitôt pour un
journaliste remet bonne en l'occurrence
et vahid est allé sur internet dans un
site officiel cherchant à connaître
l'état des lieux français s'agissant du
cyanure résultats il y à bien une
centaine de sites répertoriés en france
où sont stockés de façon plus ou moins
stricte des produits aussi dangereux
dont le siège du reportage avec pierre
moscovitch le cyanure
la france elle ou si on est victime sur
le site internet du ministère de
l'environnement
une liste de 109 zone empoisonné sur
tout le territoire usine à gaz des
charges ancienne mine d'or comme abu de
lierre dans le limousin avec ses 500
mille tonnes de déchets contenant du
cyanure à doses importantes ou encore
comme dans cette ancienne mine d'or de
salsigne dans l'aude abandonner des
déchets toxiques et polluants par
centaines de tonnes
car pour extraire l'or de la roche le
cyanure est quasiment indispensable
ce produit va concentrer le métal
précieux présents dans le minerai au
bout de la chaîne lors bien sûr mais
aussi une sorte de soupe ultra toxique
c'est elle qui s'est déversée il ya
quelques semaines dans une rizière
roumaine elle qui détruit faune et flore
implacablement une fois le le front
auxilois sait on ne devrait pas avoir de
persistance des phénomènes de toxicité
cessé dans la faune et la flore ayant
disparu
il faudra repeupler probablement qui
pourra se faire de façon naturelle
depuis laval mais qui va prendre
beaucoup de temps il n'y a pas que
l'europe de l'est à souffrir de ce mal
suède espagne portugal italie irlande
dans ces pays aussi les risques de
pollution au cyanure par infiltration
des versements sont importants d'après
le fonds mondial pour la nature dans ces
régions contaminées
l'utilisation de l'eau est interdite
tout comme la consommation de légumes et
de fruits car aval est inhalée ou même
absorbé par la peau
le cyanure est un poison mortel au
kosovo après les violents incidents de
ces dernières 48 heures à mitrovica
des perquisitions ont été effectuées par
la force multinationale de paix la kfor
40 personnes ont été arrêtées et un
couvre-feu était en vigueur ce matin
dans cette ville de mitrovica
commentaires patrice romedenne
aujourd'hui on en terre avenue il meurt
à 37 en laissant une veuve cinq enfants
et un cortège d'albanais dont les pleurs
n'en doutons pas sont autant de
promesses de vengeance qui l'a tué
acerbe impossible un soldat français de
la kfor c'est ce que disent ses amis qui
prétendent qu'il était désarmé quand il
est tombé
hélas dans ce pays où le mensonge et la
précision reste les choses les mieux
partagées du monde
il s'avère une fois de plus impossible
d'élucider l'enchaînement des événements
d'autant que quelques irréductibles ont
opté pour la stratégie du harcèlement
nous savons que des deux bords
absolument des deux bords des
extrémistes essaie de maintenir le chaos
dans cette ville
ce n'est pas acceptable nous ferons tout
pour y arriver mais je demande surtout à
la population de mitrovic à de nous
aider comme elle l'a fait hier
d'ailleurs dans les deux sur les deux
rives en restant calme car ce que craint
la kfor c'est l'embrasement de mitrovica
une ville pas comme les autres la seule
où réside encore une communauté serbe
digne de ce nom
ils sont au nord les serbes au sud les
albanais entre eux gardé en permanence
ce pont qui enjambe la rivière ibar
maison l'inconnu frontières plus étanche
la preuve on passe d'une rive à l'autre
il y aura toujours un extrémiste pour
aller régler ses comptes en france fût
ce sur le dos des soldats français de
blessés hier dans leurs rangs aussi les
hommes de la kfor respecte chaque maison
pour débusquer les snipers 40 suspects
arrêtés hier un serbe 39 abelanet mais
la cochetière bonsoir diriez vous après
ces 48 heures que cela devait arriver
qu'il y a maintenant des promesses de
vengeance dangereuse je dirais que cela
devait arriver parce qu'une une ville
divisée entre haine hélas trop souvent
ce genre d'affrontement et tous ceux qui
veulent diviser mitrovica certainement
la ville mais aussi le kosovo sont des
faiseurs de guerre et des faiseurs de
violence je pense que nous arriverons
avec les mesures que nous avons prises
qui sont très fortes à rétablir la
sécurité et rétablir une coexistence ce
ne sera pas suffisant il faudra régler
le problème politique d'une ville
divisée trouver du travail ne pas
imposer que les serbes et les albanais
vivant ensemble pour le moment ça
viendra mais plus tard rétablir la
circulation
le retour de ceux qui ont été chassés
ces quelques jours trouver du travail
c'est très long ça a pris des années
partout il n'y a pas de raison qu'ils
créent des miracles ici
bernard kouchner depuis plusieurs mois
d'une manière solennelle quelquefois un
peu triste vous avez semblé être obligé
de mendier l'aide pourtant annonce
et l'aide promise que je devais apporter
beaucoup de pays est ce que vous êtes
toujours dans l'impression que personne
ne tient ses promesses
non il faut pas se méprendre j'ai
beaucoup crié parce que j'avais besoin
d'argent frais pour payer les gens qui
sont ici qui ont travaillé qu'ils ne
sont pas payés depuis trois mois et
payer si peu non l'europe a été
extrêmement généreuse les pays européens
aussi
mais entre la promesse et l'argent qui
arrive il y a des mois qu'ils sont des
mois de froid vous savez il fait très
froid ici il n'y a pas d'électricité
encore ce soir et les gens doivent
nourrir leur famille alors je me suis
senti obligé de réclamer très fort et
j'ai obtenu de la france d'abord merci
du japon et de la communauté européenne
encore une fois 10 millions de dollars
en plus des 35 et puis de beaucoup plus
d'argent pour les projets il faut
comprendre que c'est la première fois
que l'onu que la communauté
internationale se trouve en charge d'une
région à gouverner entièrement à partir
de rien alors il faut de l'argent un peu
frais oui de temps en temps je tends la
main et je suis parfois un peu déçu est
ce que pour autant des renforts
policiers c'est la bonne solution
aujourd'hui jean pierre chevènement
était un peu dubitatif sur la nécessité
de ces renforts policiers
oui ça fait longtemps qu'il est
dubitatif jean pierre chevènement alors
moi je ne sais pas de quel pays on pas à
moi je parle du pays des droits de
l'homme
quand je parle des gens qui veulent que
la sécurité soit ici rétabli que les
femmes et les enfants puissent aller au
marché ou à l'école sans être menacé ça
avant que se rétablissent la tolérance
il me faut des policiers et je sais
qu'il ya des policiers volontaires en
france en particulier et je ne comprends
pas pourquoi alors que les gendarmes
français font un tel plan dit de travail
je n'ai pas de policiers français alors
que je reçois de partout
je pense que c'est une erreur et qu'il
faut la rétablir je sais la france assez
généreuse pour le faire très vite
pas trop tard c'est déjà un peu tard
j'en demande pas tellement je demande
qu'on n'oublie pas que pour assurer la
sécurité il faut des forces de police et
que ces forces de police je le sais sont
souvent volontaires pour venir alors que
parmi les cinq pays
on appelle ça les queens l'italie
l'allemagne l'angleterre les états unis
et la france nous ne soyons pas le seul
pays qui n'ait pas envoyé d'officiers de
police très compétents comme je les
collais merci verdun kouchner en
tchétchénie le commandement russe décidé
d'interdire l'entrée de grozny la
capitale aux civils les militaires vol
nettoyée selon leur jargon la ville des
mines et des obus distille mais ils
veulent également empêcher que des
rebelles s'infiltre officiellement selon
moscou l'armée russe a infligé de très
lourdes pertes aux indépendantistes
tchétchènes
mais pas un mot en revanche sur les
exactions commises par les militaires
russes
et pourtant les témoignages se succèdent
sur des exécutions sommaires dès hier
dans cette édition nos envoyés spéciaux
dorothée lyrique éditeurs nous
adressaient des témoignages en voici
d'autres après plusieurs jours passés en
tchétchénie sous contrôle des forces
russes
ce que l'occident découvre aujourd'hui
sur les candy de filtration eux le
savent depuis longtemps
et puisqu'aujourd'hui tout homme valide
né en tchétchénie risque de perdre la
vie dans un camp russe ils ont choisi de
risquer la leur en combattant dans les
montagnes du sud sur les camps de
filtration les tchétchène réfugié en
ingouchie raconte pratiquement tous la
même histoire
là bas on qu on tue les jeunes on les a
mais ne sais pas trop ils disparaissent
dans les gants et torturent les gens
d'électricité quand ils reviennent ils
sont handicapés à vie à cause des
tortures il n'y a pas que les camps de
filtration les récits d'exactions se
multipliaient son concours dans l'armée
russe ne fait pas seulement la guerre
aux terroristes comme elle dit mais
aussi au peuple tchétchène tout entier
mon voisin m'a dit que dans le village
talent les rues sont fusillés 80
personnes que des jeunes à partir de
l'âge de trésors année pas hier l esma
trois femmes d'un camp de réfugiés sont
tourné en tchétchénie voient leurs
maisons les rues les ont arrêté leur ont
bandé les yeux et leur ont tiré une
balle dans la terre chaque jour à la
frontière entre la tchétchénie et
ingouchie
des femmes viennent provoquer les
soldats des forces fédérales elles
brandissent des banderoles de fortune
pour dénoncer les massacres on à ma faim
le monde il doit ouvrir les yeux sur
l'extermination du peuple tchétchène
l'armée russe a annoncé aujourd'hui que
l'entrée de grozny et est désormais
interdit aux civils
il y en avait au moins 10000 terrés dans
les caves pendant les bombardements
que sont ils devenus dans le silence
complice des ruines l'armée russe
poursuit ce qu'elle appelle son
nettoyage sans témoin dans la série que
sont ils devenus je rappelle car il faut
pas l'oublier
le photographe français brice fleutiaux
enlevée le 1er octobre 99 est toujours
retenu en otage quelque part au sud de
la tchétchénie à bruxelles avant même
d'évoquer les réformes des institutions
européennes ce fut l'autriche qui
alimentait les discussions la ministre
des affaires étrangères autrichienne
madame benita ferrero waldner que voici
membre du parti conservateur autrichien
a minimisé le rôle de jörg haider et
rappelé l'engagement européen de son
pays les autres ministres chargés des
affaires européennes de monsieur
dominici a été présent par mais ils
représentent les 15 membres de l'union
européenne d'autant plus présent qu'il
s'agit de revoir de fond en comble ou
presque les institutions européennes et
leur fonctionnement il est encore plus
difficile de s'entendre à 25 ou 30 qu'à
15 c'est pourtant ce qui devrait arriver
si tous les pays candidats à l'europe
sont admis il faut donc modifier les
procédures de prise de décision c'est ce
que l'on a commencé à faire aujourd'hui
à bruxelles
l'explication thiriez et jean jacques le
garrec un nouveau venu ça change
toujours la face des choses la famille
européenne elle s'apprête à accueillir
douze petits nouveaux
d'où une conférence intergouvernementale
car on ne décide pas à 21,27 le france
comme on le fait à 15 voici l'europe
aujourd'hui
mais depuis 98 des négociations sont en
cours pour l'entrée vers 2003 de la
république tchèque l'estonie la hongrie
la pologne la slovénie et chypre et plus
tard une deuxième phase d'élargissement
est prévue avec deux problèmes la
bulgarie et la turquie
je pense vraiment qu'il n'y a pas
suffisamment réfléchi c'est le problème
des frontières de l'europe
jusqu'où va le rat si nous disons oui
aujourd'hui à la turquie a qui diront
non demain actuellement la communauté
européenne ces onze langues
de nombreux traducteurs et des tonnes de
papier comment éviter le gigantisme des
infrastructures car l'europe c'est comme
une voiture plus ont la charge
- roule vite à moins de changer de
moteur c'est pourquoi la première
mission de cette conférence
intergouvernementale va être d'envisager
la réforme de toutes les institutions
européennes à la commission d'abord
faudra-t-il à l'avenir un commissaire
par pays ou inventer un système de
tournai au parlement les textes
prévoient un maximum de 700 députés ils
sont 626 aujourd'hui comment éviter
l'enlisement à chaque décision qu'il
faudrait y avoir une europe à deux
vitesses avec des accords de coopération
particulière d'accord car elles seront
renforcées qui permettent à ceux qui
sont qui se voudrait les moteurs de
protéines est difficilement évitable une
europe à plusieurs étages ne se
résumerait tel pas à une zone de
libre-échange plus qu'à une union
politique au conseil des ministres aussi
les choses devraient changer car
l'arrivée de nombreux pays d'europe
centrale et orientale pourrait bien les
et les grands pays ceux qui financent le
plus comme la france ou l'allemagne
pourrait relativement facilement faire
une majorité ou le contraire une
minorité de blocage avec un nombre de
petits pays ou de paix moyens alors pour
éviter d'attraper le tournis et de faire
peur aux payeurs on devrait donc aller
vers une généralisation de la majorité
qualifiée en prenant en compte la
population des pays leur absolue lance
donc aujourd'hui dans un vrai changement
en profondeur pour ne perdre à l'avenir
ni sa vitesse d'exécution ni son âme ni
son identité et sur marie mono qui peut
bloquer qui peut vouloir bloquer cette
réforme est le premier souci ce sont les
petits pays qui sont très inquiet par la
modification de la pondération des voix
jusqu'à présent trois petits payer un
grand pouvait bloquer les votes
cette fois on va tenir compte de la
population donc c'est la prime au grand
pays
deuxième souci le vote à la majorité
qualifiée
savez vous que 42 secteur nécessite
unanimité l'unanimité cela permet à
certains pays notamment quand ils sont
concernés par la fiscalité ou la
sécurité sociale de bloquer le vote
mais ce sera la majorité qualifiée on
avancera plus vite troisième souci on
vous l'a dit le nombre de commissaires
il sera fixé à 25 en europe soit 27 pays
membres
jura des pays sans commissaire vous
imaginez la france ou l'allemagne soit
commissaire difficile mais que c'est une
réforme très ambitieuse du jamais vu
depuis 40 ans dans quel but
on vous l'a dit l'élargissement dix mois
pour réussir
fin des travaux à nice sous présidence
française avec peut-être le traité de
nice qui consacrera l'élargissement de
l'europe merci christian marie lafrance
une nouvelle fois rappelé à l'ordre par
le conseil de l'europe en matière
judiciaire
il s'agit du sort d'abdelhamid hakkar
cet homme de 43 ans a été condamnée il
ya onze ans à la réclusion à perpétuité
pour le meurtre d'un policier commis en
1984 d'el hamid hakkar a toujours nié
être coupable il a été jugé en son
absence
après seize années de prison conseil de
l'europe estime qu'il n'y a toujours pas
eu de procès équitable etc abdelamid
hakkar est toujours présumé innocent
enquête stéphane breitner et dominique
bonnet l'un en français l'autre et
néerlandais mandatés par le conseil de
l'europe deux parlementaires en visite à
fresnes voilà une première
l'afer qui les amène ses selles
d'abdelhamid hakkar incarcéré depuis 16
ans pour un meurtre qu'il a toujours nié
l'histoire commence le 1er septembre
1984 il est arrêté avec neuf autres
complices tous membres d'un gang
spécialisé dans les braquages
la veille lors d'une course poursuite un
policier a été abattu cinq ans
d'instruction
abdelhamid hakkar est condamné à la
perpétuité problème il n'était pas
présent à son procès et sans avocat pour
le défendre
ce dossier empoisonne la justice
française en 95 abdelamid hakkar dépose
plainte devant la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme la france est
condamnée à réviser le procès
une obligation qu'elle n'a jamais
respecté cinq années de silence trop
long pour les proches d'abdelhamid pour
la famille c'est hyper long sincèrement
je vais parler très simplement on n'en
peut plus aujourd'hui les îles à il
entame une grève de la faim depuis un
mois et dans les landes puis du fatigué
moralement comme physiquement et les
plans gay
cette visite un premier pas vers
l'application du droit a refait ce qui
était totalement inadmissible c'était un
homme dont le procès avait été considéré
comme non conforme aux droits de l'homme
ne puisse pas obtenir le droit à
révision de son procès à ce jour seules
la france et la turquie ne respectait
pas les décisions de la cour de
strasbourg
mais jeudi dernier lors du débat sur la
présomption d'innocence les députés
votent un amendement toute condamnation
de la france par la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme est un motif de
révision d'un procès pénal
autrement dit la révision du procès
hakkar est désormais possible
une découverte macabre au sud de rodez
dans l'aveyron dans le village de flavin
2000 habitants deux cadavres ceux d'une
femme 150 viennent de 12 ans étaient
retrouvées par le mari de cette femme
aux drogues s'est ajoutée la disparition
d'un bébé
un bébé âgé d'un mois de ceux qui vivent
dans cette maison au centre du village
de flavin un périmètre de sécurité mis
en place par les gendarmes autour de la
maison
sur les deux millions d'étudiants
français 5 % d'entre eux environ cent
mille vivent sous ce que l'on appelle
pudiquement le seuil de pauvreté en fait
c'est un rapport sur les aides sociales
étudiantes commandé par le ministère qui
a été rendu public aujourd'hui et qui
utilise lui même les mots de situations
misère ou de pauvreté pour ces étudiants
souvent obligé de renoncer aux études
faute de revenus suffisants
explication la vida taboury tous les
étudiants ne sont pas financièrement
égaux face aux études les jeunes issus
de milieux modestes sont bien souvent
obligés de limiter leurs ambitions à des
études courtes et seulement 6% d'entre
eux acceptent à un troisième cycle
c'est à dire un doctorat alors qu'ils
étaient encore 17% en dunk pour financer
leurs études
cette formule étudiants travaillent soit
un sur trois face à cette précarité
grandissante
jean-francis d'aurillac
préconise la mise en place d'une
allocation de 20 mille francs par an à
tous les étudiants de niveau maîtrise
des ss et des oeufs
la majoration de 25% des bourses sur
critères sociaux lors du passage en
licence et la création d'un véritable
revenu étudiants pour les anciens
boursiers qui parviennent à accéder à un
troisième cycle
selon le rapport il ya urgence puisque
plus de cent mille étudiants 10 en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté
un chiffre que le ministère de
l'éducation jugé exagéré le montant
maximum c'est un rappel d'une bourse est
de 1700 francs par mois ces deux
disparaissent en troisième site seule
alternative donc si l'on veut continuer
à trouver un travail c'est le cas de
cette étudiante elle est à l'université
de villetaneuse en seine-saint-denis
elle raconte sa débrouille allamargot
jean luc boussard plusieurs après-midi
par semaine
tiphaine quitte la fac pour travailler
dans les services financiers d'un grand
magasin les petits boulots elle les
enchaîne depuis le lycée dans sa jeune
vie d'étudiante
il n'y a guère de place pour les loisirs
quand je suis pas là l'autonomie n'est
pas toujours un choix
tiphaine à quatre autres soeurs ses
parents ne pouvaient financer la
totalité de ses études pour payer sa
chambre en résidence universitaire elle
a obtenu une bourse et qui est loin de
couvrir tous ses besoins
mais à force année 1366 francs par mois
et mon loyer tel 900 mhz 44 donc ça
suffit pas non parce que c'est le
premier c'est sans compter tout ce qui
est à l'ifa toursky nourriture et s'il
faut éventuellement aux médecins en
forme affronter ça et c'est sans compter
la mutuelle à payer tous les mois
donc non ça suffit pas les couilles pour
concilier le travail et les études qui
feignent mise tout sur l'examen de fin
d'année si elle le rate
comme tous les redoublants elle perdra
sa bourse les étudiants issus de
familles modestes sont pénalisés par
rapport à ceux qui peuvent se consacrer
à leurs études
la plupart s'arrêteront à bac + 2 pour
des raisons financières
on se rend compte qu'aujourd'hui un
étudiant en 2ème ou 3ème cycle et issus
de familles
très favorisés fils de cadres cadres
supérieurs dirigeants d'entreprises
alors que il n'ya par exemple que 6 %
d'enfants d'ouvriers en troisième cycle
est ce que tu fais une déclaration aux
inégalités s'ajoute la jungle de l'aide
sociale les syndicats étudiants qui aide
les jeunes en difficulté à constituer
leur dossier dénonce les critères
d'attribution fantaisiste de
l'allocation d'études mise en place à la
rentrée dernière
le crous d'orléans exclu par définition
tout étudiant salarié de bénéfice de
l'allocation d'étude au nom du fait que
comme il est salarié il un revenu dont
il n'a pas besoin des aides et le crous
de aix marseille par exemple exclu par
définition tout étudiant qui ne serait
pas salarié parce qu'il n'aurait pas
apporté la preuve qu'il est autonome
pierre angulaire du plan social étudiant
de claude allègre cette nouvelle
allocation s'adresser aux jeunes
défavorisés
mais seul un millier de ces aides a été
distribué qu'en sept cent mille
étudiants sont contraints de travailler
pour financer leurs études
le ras-le-bol de leurs conditions de
travail les salariés de l'hypermarché
continent de wasquehal c'est près de
roubaix en or ont déclenché une grève
très largement suivie à l'origine de ce
mécontentement
selon les syndicats des faits de
harcèlement moral et des pressions jugé
inacceptable tout ça sur fond de
négociations difficiles de la réduction
du temps de travail
ces deux derniers jours à paris les
spécialistes cancérologue ont abordé la
question des formes héréditaires du
cancer du sein
5 % des femmes atteintes par un cancer
sont concernés là il y a deux manières
d'aborder cette situation aux états unis
on pratique préventivement l'ablation
des deux seins et des deux ovaires dès
que sont connus des risques de
développement de l'anomalie mais en
europe les médecins ne sont pas
favorables ce principe de précaution la
décision est difficile à prendre comme
le nombre de témoignages de cette femme
concernée interrogé par jean daniel
flaysakier et blaise grenier quand marc
est chauveau feuillette l'album de
photos de sa famille hollandaise il y à
un mot qui revient très souvent alors là
vous voyez ma soeur ma soeur lisa s'est
massé ma soeur qui m'a élevée puisque
j'ai perdu ma mère quand j'avais onze
mans
aussi suite à un cancer des seins ma
soeur est là le cancer des seins aussi à
l'âge de 52 ans
je vais vous montrer aussi une photo de
ma soeur aînée hockey qui chante avec
mes filles qui est là c'est aussi
atteint d'un cancer des seins cette
forme héréditaires de cancers est rare
à peine 5 % des cas marette sera à la
fin mars si elle est aussi porteuses de
l'anomalie génétique elle devra
peut-être alors prendre une décision
difficile subir à moyen terme l'ablation
des deux seins ce que l'on appelle une
mammectomie à titre préventif
malheureusement je pense que c'est un
geste quand même très lourd et beaucoup
de conséquences je ne suis pas encore
vraiment prête à le faire mais s'il
s'agit de survie si je suis amené à
faire pour survivre
je pense que effectivement fait
d'envisager des milliers d'américaines
porteuse de la même anomalie ont choisi
de se faire enlever les seins et parfois
les ovaires sans que le cancer souhaite
à parle mais les spécialistes européens
pensent qu'il faut repousser le plus
loin possible l'échéance d'une telle
opération en général la réponse
chirurgicale c'est d'essayer d'éviter
une mutilation parce qu'on s'est d'une
part qu'elle est irréversible d'autre
part que si on était amené à faire cette
intervention la feraient parfois pour
des patients qui ne développeront pas le
cancer et enfin que bien que les
techniques de reconstruction soit je
dirais aux deux toujours en train d'être
amélioré une reconstruction du sein ne
rend pas le 5 ont arrangé
si le test est positif m'arrête
bénéficiera d'une surveillance et de
conseil génétique et psychologique
en attendant et en espérant l'arrivée de
traitements médicaux mais aussi de la
thérapie génique qui éviteront des
mutilations certes préventive mais
toujours mal vécu
une double situation menaçante la
réunion le volcan du piton de la
fournaise est entré en éruption dans la
nuit dernière mais ils ne présentent
aucun danger selon la préfecture de la
réunion
en revanche une alerte cyclonique qui
étaient déclenchés dans la soirée en
raison de la proche d'une tempête
tropicale qui pourrait également touché
l'île maurice en moins d'un mois c'est
un deuxième passage de cyclone qui
affecte cette partie de l'océan indien
alliès vahramian et bernard connor pour
france 2 était à la réunion juste après
la dernière tempête à la réunion ces
intempéries sont connus des mesures
particulières de précautions sont prises
ce qui limite les dégâts à comparaison
de ce qui peut se passer en métropole
nous sommes sur la route de mme aido à
900 mètres d'altitude la hourre
métropole des dizaines de milliers
d'arbres sont tombés à la réunion le
cyclone en a emporté que quelques
milliers les plus vieux la forêt
tropicale a tenu parce qu'elle est dense
peu élevé 10 15 m parce que les yeux
calyptus et les tamarins tiennent bien
parce que les arbres sont simplement
différent ici du continent totalement
différent surtout systèmes basse mer
étant assez profond et en même temps le
sol et quand même caillouteux et
et très alimenté par l'humidité donc une
bonne pénétration dans le sol ces arbres
là les maisons même les plus modestes
ont elles aussi tenu il n'y a pas ici de
toits arrachés chez ce maraîcher comme
partout sur l'immersion ce sont des
tôles et non les tuiles qui couvrent
l'habitation
ça fait que sur
c'est un toit comme cette maison il ya à
peu près 2000 à 2500 vis ce qui est
quand même énorme alors pour que sa part
il faut qu'il y ait quand même des vents
très violents quoi pendant les 24 heures
du cyclone edvard de la drogue n'est pas
resté cloîtré chez lui il était au
milieu de ces cultures qu'il a perdu à
100% depuis plusieurs années en
prévention il renforce ses serres là
elles ont tenu ici pour couvrir ses
tomates il avait importés de métropole
un système de deux feuilles plastiques
séparés par de l'air censés atténuer
l'effet du vent je veux dire quand même
fait été efficace 14 heures pendant 14
heures le vent a soufflé avec des
rafales quand même assez dur de 120 à
150 km heure et ça a tenu hier à 18h le
soir où ça a lâché bombe un peu les
bâches dégonflée par les coupures de
courant et tout bon mais ça c'est ça
peut pas tenir éternellement mais en
général à la réunion les cyclones ne
dure pas tout ce temps quoi
la saison des cyclones lure a jusqu'en
avril mais dans un mois
le maraîcher a promis que kony ne serait
plus qu'un mauvais souvenir
hors du temps qui est le nôtre avec ses
bons et ses mauvais côtés ces tempêtes
et ces périodes calmes le spéléologue
michel siffre aura vécu depuis le 30
novembre dernier sous la terre dans la
grotte de clamouse perdant souvent le
sens des heures et des jours
aujourd'hui il est revenu sous un ciel
bleu dans l'hérault après être passé de
1999 à l'an 2000 loin de tout de tout le
monde pour une expérience scientifique
récit véronique gaglione l'événement de
tunis
de ses 69 jours hors du temps il est
revenu avec une barbe blanche un peu de
fatigue et de lassitude et le souvenir
pour lui tout seul d'un bivouac
silencieux à 900 mètres sous terre
j'ai fait quand même dans un
environnement coupé de tout refaire
pendant plus de deux mois il a vécu à
son rythme sans que les solitudes le
gène de +10 pc basse et surtout les
manipulations biologique là je porte une
descente dans le cul excusez-moi cardio
à 61 ans et sa troisième expérience hors
du temps et c'est précisément tout
l'intérêt scientifique de cet isolement
les données recueillies cette année
pourront être comparées à celles d'il ya
28 et 38 ans avec différentes
applications de l'étude des dépressions
aux troubles du sommeil ou autre maladie
par exemple le mal les maux de tête
comme les migraines qui ont des
tendances art se reproduire de manière
inique le traitement de maladies
sérieuses comme le cancer que maintenant
c'est peuvent être traités plus
efficacement ce les drogues sont
administrées selon un rythme circadien
au michel siffre l'expérience arrêtera
vraiment dans dix jours lorsqu'il
quittera ses électrodes
mais ce soir déjà il est revenu dans
notre temps n'oubliez pas que les
grottes c'est un monde minéral un
minéral complet il n'ya pas y'a pas ça
y'a pas de la vie où elle est
microscopique là c'est bon quoi de voir
le vert la couleur verte par exemple
michel siffre
bonsoir comment allez-vous d'abord je
vais bien honnêtement je vais très bien
je me sens en pleine forme puis je suis
un petit peu excité quand même là je
commence à accuser un peu de fatigue
parce qu'on a eu une journée quand même
vous vous en doutez bien agitée oui puis
je crois qu'il est important de vous
épaulent temps de prendre un bain ce qui
était quand même une deux premiers un de
vos premiers désirs et sa wii pour être
avec vous en plus parce qu'il est resté
que quelques minutes pour
passé dans le journal le retour de la
grotte de clamouse et il faut que je
suis appareiller avec des appareils
je tiens j'ai la tv une prise de
température
j'ai des appareils pour mesurer mon
coeur en permanence si bien que j'ai pas
eu le temps alors il faudra que je
repousse à demain par contre j'ai eu le
temps de donner un coup de téléphone à
ma maman qu'est ce qui vous a le plus
manqué michel siffre
qu'est ce qui m'a le plus manqué bon
vous savez dans ces expériences
on y va très motivés sinon on les fait
pas qu'est ce qu'ils peuvent avoir
beaucoup manqué vont d'abord les
problèmes d'hygiène ça a été un vrai
problème
on n'a pas d'eau courante naturellement
c'est pas comme dans un laboratoire dans
un hôpital mais qu'est ce que je peux
dire ce qui m'a le plus manqué je veux
dire c'est la motivation du travail j'ai
très peu travaillé et bien le le fait
d'avoir plutôt utiliser mon temps à lire
à m'occuper de manière pas scientifique
parce que j'ai pas cherché à faire de la
recherche
j'ai l'expérience est une expérience
scientifique de haut niveau
bien sûr mais moi même j'ai pas essayé
de travailler de lire des travaux
scientifiques
j'ai préféré penser réfléchir c'est
quand même j'arrive à un moment de la
vie
c'est la troisième expérience que je
fais dans ma vie je suis presque resté
en tout trois cent quarante jours sous
terre
voilà presque un an sous terre mais
justement michel cela vous avez eu une
expérience fascinante 62 ans 872 à
nouveau cette année seriez pas un peu
maso quand même d'aller vous enfermez
hors du temps non vous savez la vie hors
du temps d'avant c'est une vie très
agréable dans la mesure où justement on
vit selon ses pulsions alimentaires
quand j'ai faim je mange quand j'ai soif
je bois quand j'ai besoin de dormir
quand j'avais dormi
eh bien je vais dormir alors qu'à la
surface de la terre c'est pas la même
chose en plus il n'y a pas de stimulus
lumineux qui le réveille
bon ceci dit je vais vous dire quand je
me réveillais j'allumais ma lumière en
la chance a voulu que j'étais dans une
caverne splendide et autour de moi
j'avais choisi un emplacement qui
m'avait été autorisé par la grotte de
clamouse au milieu de concrétions
extraordinaire et donc j'avais un
confort psychologique
que je n'ai trouvé dans une autre grotte
parce que rappelez-vous en 62 c'était
dur j'étais sur un gamin et souterrains
et là c'était vraiment très dur
physiquement
merci beaucoup vie choisie on faisait
très très longtemps parce que je pense
que vous auriez beaucoup de choses à
nous raconter
mais merci beaucoup c'est la fin de ce
journal donc on vous retrouvera cette
man pour nous raconter encore d'autres
choses sur cette expérience pire chimie
ccif c'est juste la formation vous
donner sur le sport le rugby la mauvaise
nouvelle pour le quinze de france qui
affrontera samedi l'angleterre au stade
de france pour le tournoi des six
nations le demi d'ouverture christophe
lamaison atteint d'une entorse au genou
droit et forfait il sera remplacé par
stéphane glace de l'équipe de bourgoin
et puis ce dernier hommage solennel du
cinéma français de ces acteurs de ces
réalisateurs à roger vadim lors d'une
cérémonie à l'église
saint-germain-des-prés aujourd'hui sa
femme marie christine barrault mais
aussi catherine deneuve anouk aimée
c'est une fanny ardant france aux armes
aussi robert hossein puis en octobre
riches étaient présents dans
l'assistance où se trouvent également
plusieurs personnalités politiques dont
le journal nice matin brigitte bardot
affirmait-il hier j'ai tout perdu
en perdant va dit voilà nous arrivons à
la fin de cette édition je rappelle aux
informations que nous avons développé la
pollution au cyanure après la roumanie
la hongrie atteint maintenant le danube
non loin de belgrade en france plus
d'une centaine de sites sont répertoriés
comme détenant des stocks de cyanure
et puis la force internationale de paix
au kosovo arrête 40 personnes suspectées
d'avoir participé aux violences du
distributeur bernard kouchner en direct
à solliciter un immense a déploré un
manque de moyens solliciter des
policiers dans quelques instants la
météo avec isabelle martinet à 20h50
bien évidemment la saint valentin les
amours spéciaux de jean luc reichmann à
23h05 argent public le magazine avait
que six plaintes à la serrure 50 le
journal de la nuit qui vous sera
présenté par thierry thuillier demain
sur 50 dans les 4 vérités gérard morin
recevra philippe seguin et puis à
travers votre vrai qu'à rodez faire et
rachid arhab à demain 20h bonsoir merci